we are from the cast of marvel studios
eternals and here's everything you need
to know about our film in 60 seconds
boom big bang the universe comes into
existence powerful beings known as the
celestials roam the universe i think the
infinity stones show up maybe i don't i
don't know that explains so much
powerful celestial creates the eternals
that's us the original superheroes
5000 bc suddenly the deviants emerged to
destroy all life of existence
they are literally the worst as the
eternals are sent to earth aboard a
giant spaceship named the domo and save
humanity from extinction you're welcome
fast forward hundreds of years the
eternals eliminate the last two deviants
and decide to break up
gilgamesh larry's a delicious buy recipe
cersei starts dating dan whitman a dank
hashtag dreamboat thanos destroys half
of all life in the universe super
annoying but the avengers save the day
and bring everyone back yay out of
nowhere these annoying deviants return
with a vengeance now the eternals must
reunite to protect humanity once again
it is time
did we do it did we we're done i think
we did it don't miss eternals it's here
in 10 days